[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
cloud key management can help you manage
encryption keys on google cloud cloud
key management allows you to create
import and manage cryptographic keys and
perform cryptographic operations in a
single centralized cloud service
cloud key management allows you to
centrally manage symmetrical
and asymmetrical encryption keys for
your cloud services the same way you do
on-premises
you can generate use rotate and destroy
these cryptographic keys
cloud key management allows you to
enable hardware key security with a
hardware security model hsms
you can toggle between software and
hardware protect encryption keys with a
press of a button you can also encrypt
data in bigquery and compute engine and
other services with encryption keys that
are stored and managed in third-party
key management
external key manager allows you to keep
your encryption keys on prem while still
leveraging the power of cloud for
compute and analytics
cloud key management is very easy to set
up you can either enable cloud key
management services in google cloud
console or use the api
the pricing model is simple it is a
pay-as-you-go model and you are charged
based on different products you use in
cloud key management so next time you're
looking to manage encryption keys take a
minute to look at cloud key management
to learn more check out cloud.google.com
security key management
[Music]
you